Ooh, finally a lighter story who cause those?
Man, um, lighter but serious in a way. Not
too serious. But I think it's ironic Donald
Trump, remember when Donald Trump said that
he would not play golf as president? If you
need a reminder, here's a clip.
I Love Golf. I think it's one of the greats,
but I don't have time, 250 around set support
than a guy who plays on the PGA Tour Place
Obama Audit, get off the golf course and get
down there. Everything's executive order because
he doesn't have enough time cause he's playing
so much golf. He doesn't have enough time
to convince Congress to do it. So I have the
greatest stuff. But you know what? And I love
golf. But if I were in the White House, I
don't think I'd ever see turn very again.
I just want to stay in the White House and
worked by Sol. So Trump was like, I don't
have time for, for
golf. I'm not going to because I'm going to
be working. Well, it turns out that Donald
Trump's golf trips alone cost the nation 255
times more than his salary. Right? So I mean,
what's the point? Uh, so the actual estimated
total is $102 million to date that the president
of the United States has, um, that the president
of the United States has spent just to play
golf for no other reasons, for no other reasons,
but to play golf. I'm the president also like
to brag that he's not taking a salary, but
who needs a salary? Who needs a salary when
you're spending this kind of money? And most
of the time you're spending this type of money
at a Trump facility, right? So there's been
well documented how the nation is, is actually
enriching Donald Trump privately because every
time we go tomorrow, Lygo every time he goes
to a Trump hotel, every time he goes to a
Trump resort, the nation is pay our tax payer
dollars are paying millions of dollars into
his personal.
And Professional. A coffers and and conservative
seem to have no problem with this whatsoever
because they're not concerned about the detail.
They're concerned about. The political wind
always remembered that they don't, there's,
they don't see anything is hypocrisy because
for them the ends justify the means. So if
that means they have to ignore the fact that
the president has played golf more than probably
any other president in history, certainly
more golf than Barack Obama and cost of his
trips represent 255 times his annual salary
than what good is a is the fact that he's
not taking the salary, but yet they'll still
brag. They will still, conservatives will
still get online and brag about the fact that
he's donating his salary. Well, yeah. Hell,
I would donate my salary too if you're spending
$102 million on trips for me to go around
and play golf and I don't even like golf,
but I digress.
It just speaks to where we are in this country,
man. We are really, we're really in a place
where the truth does not matter. We are in
a place where facts don't matter it this,
this is irrelevant news. This honestly, and
in the broader scheme of American politics
today where we are Donald Trump, this is irrelevant
news. However, if you take this exact story,
fast forward two years, two and a half years,
when a Democratic president is empowered and
they spin $102 million on a golf trip, then
suddenly it would become all the news. We
know about this. One thing would be enough
for Republicans to impeach a Democrat because
it is grossly irresponsible. It is a gross
violation of the monuments clause. I mean,
he is spending money and enriching himself
on the American taxpayers dime. So this in
about three years would be enough for Republicans
to impeach, but today it's barely news.
See, this is Donald Trump. Donald Trump has
the park. He's like, the Trifecta has the
TRIFECTA. It's probably more, but I'm going
to try to summarize it into three. He has
a party that has no backbone to no spine and
they absolutely loved the policies that he's
implementing, so they're going to tolerate
it. He has a base that does not care, they
will follow him to hell and back again. They
would betray Jesus as much as they try to
force Jesus on you. They would be trade Jesus
on behalf of their master Donald Trump. And
he has absolutely no shame himself. So with
that try affect the, he can get away with
these types of things and the new cycle is
inundated with his ridiculousness. So much
so that there has been any number of m p o
p impeachable offenses that have taken place
over the last two and a half years, that if
you just take one Democrat is impeached just
one.
And yet here we have probably hundreds, literally
hundreds of new stories, some, some new cycles.
We don't have even have enough time, right?
There's some stories that are important that
we don't even have enough time to cover because
we're so inundated. And that's a part of his
strategy that literally is a part of a strategy.
And we as a media infrastructure, uh, media,
um, arm, the fourth estate, uh, along with
the checks and balances of the house and the
Senate. Um, we, we were not equipped to come
back this type of onslaught from a president
and the party and a base that are completely
complicit with what he does
and with what he says. And so this is how
the president of the United States can get
away with spending $102 million on golf trips.
Jess, in about two and a half,